[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour un
dimanche en politique spéciale nous
sommes en direct ce matin du quartier
battant de besançon sur la terrasse du
café le bras célian d' jusqu'à midi nous
allons nous interroger ensemble sur la
manière dont chacun d'entre nous se
déplace en ville alors que les
automobilistes sont encore très
largement majoritaire leur présence est
de plus en plus contesté piétons et
cyclistes se font davantage de place
chaque jour alors faut-il aller plus
loin bouter les voitures hors de nos
centres ne favoriseront pas trop les
vélos comment garantir la sécurité
notamment des plus faire des plus
fragiles on va en débattre avec nos
quatre invités je vous les présente tout
de suite d'abord marie zehaf bonjour
vous êtes adjointe au maire de besançon
en charge de la voirie des déplacements
et des infrastructures vous êtes
socialiste également sur ce plateau en
plein air lift ketterer président de
l'association trottoirs libre une
association qui milite pour que les
trottoirs reviennent aux piétons hugo
l'allemand de l'association vélo
besançon qui défend les intérêts des
cyclistes dans la capitale comtoise et
patrick joubert délégué pour la franche
comté de l'automobile club
l'automobile club qui bien sûr
représentent les automobilistes bonjour
à tous les quatre merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
alors vous en avez l'habitude cette
émission c'est aussi la vôtre vous
pouvez interpeller nos invités leur
poser vos questions en vous rendant sur
la page de l'émission sur le site
internet de france 3 bourgogne de
franche-comté et puis vous pouvez aussi
commenter l'émission sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le modeste qui s'affiche
dit mme paul fc comme dimanche en
politique franche comté je me ferai le
relais de quelques-unes de vos réactions
et elles sont nombreuses depuis le début
de la semaine
tout au long de ce débat alors madame
messieurs pendant longtemps l'espace
urbain dédié aux transports se partager
en gros en deux d'un côté il y avait les
voitures de l'autre les piétons et puis
les cyclistes se sont fait une place
tout petit au départ de plus en plus
importants pas assez certes pour les
courtisans de la petite reine trop
néanmoins pour ses détracteurs
hugo l'allemand y at il aujourd'hui dans
nos villes de la place pour tout le
monde alors de la place y en a
c'est intéressant le mot place parce que
quand on parle les différents modes de
déplacement les piétons les cyclistes
les automobilistes autre mode et on se
rend compte que c'est les automobilistes
qui prennent le plus de places de part
la superficie de la voiture voiture qui
sert à se déplacer mais qui est à
l'arrêt le plus longtemps du temps on se
rend compte que c'est la place réservée
à l'automobile
même au centre au sein d'un centre ville
qui est assez petit comme celui de
besançon est assez important et donc on
se rend compte qu'il est difficilement
partager patrick joubert les
automobilistes sont encore les bienvenus
en ville ils peuvent être que les
bienvenus on représente 80 % quand même
en mobilité
ce qui veut dire que si les français
pouvaient se déplacer autrement il le
ferait mais ça s'améliore tous les jours
en 2018
on a plus que 50% des smith qui prennent
quotidiennement leur voiture alors qu'en
2016 en étaient à 59 %
donc en deux ans il ya quand même une
franche des deux ministres qui ont pris
conscience de l'importance de circuler
avec d'autres modes le vélo à pied alors
transports en commun c'est contraint et
forcé ou ces volontaires en ai jamais
contraint et forcé quand on prend la
voiture on est pratiquement toujours
obligés de la prendre
voilà c'est ce qu'il faut le message
c'est ça c'est facile dans une ville une
agglomération comme l'est notre pensée
au milieu rural dans ce milieu là il ya
que ce mode de déplacement avec quelques
bus transport en commun de temps en
temps s'organise les les covoiturages de
plus en plus il suffit de s'adapter mais
conviennent pas assassiner les
automobilistes ils sont là ils sont là
parce qu'on leur a dit d'être là il n'y
a pas d'autres moyens
alors on propose pas d'autre moyen de
déplacement en ville n'y a pas d'autres
moyens non je vous parle pas de la ville
et puis il ya les gens qui habitent
maintenant onze ans maintenant on va se
concentrer sur la ville non le
centre-ville de centre-ville les gens
qui ont des voitures bons candidats avec
monsieur aujourd'hui à battants on vient
faire des ces courses c'est vrai que les
gens au lieu d'utiliser les parkings
municipaux qui sans gratuit le dimanche
se mettre devant les magasins
bon ben ça c'est c'est une politique à
approfondir et là c'est la vie qui a la
main alors justement le stationnement
des automobiles c'est le combatif
ketterer avec votre association
trottoirs libre vous vous fustigez
vraiment le comportement de
certains automobilistes qui finalement
ne respecte pas l'espace dédié aux
autres alors effectivement il s'agit pas
de stigmatiser tous les automobilistes
parce que moi j'en connais qui on l'est
tous plus ou moins à un moment ou un
autre mais il ya un certain nombre
d'automobilistes qui ne veulent plus
marcher et qui empiète sur l'espace
réservé depuis toujours un la loi est
très claire il n'a jamais été autorisé
de stationner sur les trottoirs et
depuis de 16 ans il est même interdite
s'arrêter sur les trottoirs donc on a un
problème de comportement de gens qui ne
veulent plus marcher et puis on a 1
comporte un problème d'infrastructures
et surtout de de contrôle et de sanction
parce que al'inverse à besançon on
autorise les riverains à s'arrêter
ce qui est complètement illégal alors
sur la politique on va se tourner vers
les lui qui est sur ce plateau marie
zehaf c'est un combat tous les jours
d'arbitré entre les différents modes de
transport alors c'est un combat tous les
jours effectivement d'arbitrer entre les
différents modes de transport par contre
je pense qu'on a tous pris conscience
qu'il fallait que enfin notre société
change et que on évolue vers d'autres
modes de déplacement en 1950 quand on a
créé nos villes on a tout construit pour
l'automobile maintenant en vain ce mode
de pensée est totalement dépassé et
effectivement il faut qu'on évolue vers
l'intermodalité c'est à dire permettre à
des personnes qui n'ont pas d'autre
choix que c'est passer en voiture
peut-être de terminer leur course à pied
ou en vélo elle de ne pas arriver sur
nos centres villes en voiture
directement sauf que ça c'est un
discours politique
et puis il ya les actes la vie
quotidienne alors là par exemple on voit
tout autour de nous il ya des voitures
garées un peu n'importe où du coup les
gens viennent jusque jusque presqu'au
bout en voiture alors c'est un travail
de longue haleine parce qu'effectivement
ça nécessite beaucoup de concertation
beaucoup de concertation notamment avec
les commerçants qui enfin pour certains
ou encore l'idée que de voir une voiture
c'est un client pour leurs magasins
c'est totalement faux en fait on
s'aperçoit que les cyclistes et les
piétons consomment beaucoup plus que les
automobilistes
un automobiliste consomme à peu près
afin là pour cent disent les piétons et
les cyclistes et 80 % de consommation
sur un centre ville est alors pourquoi
on sanctionne pas par exemple ou
simplement fait pas respecter le code de
la route comme nous disait il faut que
je serai sur le stationnement
je serai un peu plus me direz que yves
on contrôle et on verbalise il ya un
travail de concertation avec la police
municipale qui effectivement verbalise
régulièrement les voitures qui sont un
stationnement alors ça va peut-être pas
assez vite c'est sûr on voit toujours
des voitures en stationnement
malheureusement on n'a pas un policier
derrière chaque véhicule et chaque
automobiliste alors on va parler du
respect du code de la route on a
beaucoup de questions hugo l'allemand
sur le comportement des cyclistes qui
sont régulièrement pointés du doigt par
les autres usagers je vous en ligne par
exemple c'est thierry qui nous dit les
cyclistes se comporte souvent comme des
conquérants épuisant d'arrogance ils
arrivent de partout sans prendre en
considération les piétons est ce que
cette critique vous l'entendez je
l'entends à peu près tous les joueurs
wii
quand je suis venu j'ai pourtant fait
pas fait un grand trajet j'ai vu plein
de voitures garées sur trottoirs des
voitures qui faisaient des dépasse enfin
dépassements de limites de vitesse pour
autant je sais très bien que tous les
automobilistes ne restent pas il y en a
qui respectent le code de la route donc
mais est-ce que halo vous rayonnez une
critique sur les vélos par une critique
sur les voitures parce que je trouve que
cette critique est absurde en fait
les cantons et cyclistes on a une
vitesse beaucoup moindres on ne visite
est bien meilleur et surtout on met en
danger que soi même
alors si on peut se permettre de dents
alors chirac la commune je dis pas ça je
dis que quand on quand on voit des
cyclistes qui roulent sur les trottoirs
au détriment des piétons qui donc ce qui
est illégal c'est souvent parce qu'il
n'ya pas d'endroits sécurisés pour faire
du vélo sur la route
l'incivilité et du aussi en grande
partie par le manque d'aménagement et
d'infrastructures sécurisante et qui
permettent aux gens de se sentir à leur
place sur la chaussée notamment dévolu
aux cyclistes
une autre voiture une autre réaction de
christian l'avenir des lieux
emblématiques de la ville et dans le
statut d' espace partagé le mode de
déplacement le plus rétif à la civilité
c'est le vélo ou plutôt les cyclistes
qui ne respectent aucune réglementation
des vitesses ni trottoir où les piétons
sont plus sereins surtout depuis que ces
engins sont devenus nucléaire via le
critique effectué alors attend
d'ailleurs philippe ketterer vous
représentez en quelque sorte les piétons
c'est compliqué de partager les espaces
entre entre modes doux ont valu alors
vous savez qu'on soit piéton de toutes
sortes de catégories 1 conçoit enfants
avec une trottinette piétons debout ou
piéton à 6 comme moi honnêtement on ne
se bat pas contre les cyclistes mais
avec parce que avec parce que quand on
voit qu'on a fait des infrastructures
comme le tram vous prenez l'avenue
fontaine argent ou le quai veil picard
sans penser qu'il fallait une place pour
le vélo les vélos sont coincés ils
peuvent pas ils n'ont pas le droit de
rouler sur les trottoirs et ils n'ont
pas le droit de rouler sur les voies de
tram
donc c'est compliqué pour eux pour
autant un vélo même s'il peut faire peur
à certains piétons et ça je le conçois
bien quand il arrive trop vite et sage
invite les cyclistes à être prudent
quand ils empruntent ces voies là un
vélo ne nous empêche pas de passer une
voiture nous bloque complètement maryse
et hafle les consignes notamment on va
parler de la police municipale
on demande aussi de faire respecter le
code de la route aux vélos à besançon
par exemple bien sûr la police
municipale est aussi stricte là dessus
et je pense qu'il faut pas opposer les
différents usagers en fait il ya des
automobilistes qui ne respectent pas le
code de la route qui a des cyclistes qui
ne respectent pas le code de la route il
ya des piétons qui vont aussi eu des
fois traverser n'importe où et je pense
que c'est pas en opposant les différents
usagers qu'on va réussir à avancer
ensemble
il ya un code de la route pour tout le
monde il est enfin il se doit d'être
respectée au niveau de la ville nous on
a des campagnes d'information de
sécurité au niveau des cyclistes au
niveau des voitures pareil en la
préfecture mène aussi des campagnes de
prévention routière chose qu
effectivement un coup dur à la route
doit être respectée pour tout le monde
partout le monde pour qu'on ait un
véritable enfin des espaces vraiment
partagé respecter une autre réaction
caroline qui nous écrit de champagnole
elle nous dit que chez elle les élus
pratique plutôt la culture du tout
voiture et du tout parking les
stationnements abusifs ne sont jamais
soumis à verbalisation
encore une fois on revient à quelles
sont les consignes politiques données
sur sur les villes à l'encontre des
automobilistes ou des cyclistes qui
respectent pas le code de la route
alors je connais bien champagnole en
plus il n'y a pas de stationnement
réglementé à champagnole et je pense que
le stationnement réglementé et déjà une
bonne chose pour permettre à la voiture
de respecter les espaces déjà bon alors
effectivement l'automobiliste a un peu
râlé parce qu'il faut payer son
stationnement mais ils trouvent de la
place ça lui évite de tourner dans les
rues est pollué les les rues est de
passer au milieu des piétons pour
trouver de la place mais en fait la
police municipale quand tu en as une
fait son travail
et effectivement fait respecter les
espaces patrick joubert ya encore trop
d'espacé réservé aux voitures et aux
stationnements répondent pour
champagnole quand même je veux pas être
méchant mais c'est vrai qu'il ya qu une
grande rue qui traverse la ville depuis
depuis l'arrivée jusqu'à la suisse bon
il ya quand même pas énormément à part
cette voie là pour en taxes qu'il ya
tous les commerces
il faut quand même à ce niveau là qui
est un peu de tout je pense pas qu'ils
aient beaucoup de cyclistes par rapport
à besançon c'est vrai que la
configuration maintenant il ya les vélos
électriques c'est un peu le problème
souvent 10e le vélo nucléaire ces vélos
électriques et sous thèmes sans censure
et qui j'imagine que c'est là que la
question de pression oui c'est ça il
fait référence au vélo électrique qui
développe notamment à besançon vélo
électrique est quand même bien
nécessaire à besançon aussi les cas les
cyclistes pour monter sur les sur les
collines je pense que ça a été un grand
progrès avant cette période là il y
avait quand même pas beaucoup de
cyclistes 1 sur les sur les hauteurs est
ce que vous faites partie de ces
automobilistes qui pestent régulièrement
contre les cyclistes à écouter étant
donné que je marche centre-ville j'ai
pas trop de problèmes avec les cyclistes
c'est le problème c est prendre
l'habitude de regarder à gauche avant de
partir à droite et dans avec les six qui
sont en sens interdit par rapport aux
axes des voitures bon c'est un c'est
quelque chose à prendre quand elle au
centre-ville mais il ya des tas de gens
qui savent pas que la gauche avec des
cyclistes et je pense qu'il ya pas mal
d'accidents qui sont lus à ça et les
cyclistes
vous avez plus de sonnettes sur votre
vélo non il ya encore des sonnettes
alors les sonnettes sont obligatoires
sur une partie de l'équipement
obligatoire sans un vélo chacun est
libre de le respecter et honorer c'est
sûr on les entend pas alors là je sais
pas si on a entendu bien sûr sur le
fauteuil vide ketterer il ya une
sonnette
c'est absolument indispensable pour
notre sécurité parce que effectivement
c'est parfois compliqué de circuler
je veux juste donner un petit un petit
mot très court sur les vélos électriques
nucléaires
moi je suis motorisé avec deux petits
moteurs électriques et des batteries et
je roule avec de l'énergie renouvelable
c'est possible on peut aussi se fournir
chez un fournisseur qui met de l'énergie
renouvelable dans nos machines
est ce que de manière générale il était
rare il n'y a pas un problème tout
simplement de tolérance alors de
tolérance oui mais au quotidien cancan
comme beaucoup dans deux parents
beaucoup d'automobilistes sont parents
grands parents ils se rendent pas compte
que quand ils s'arrêtent même une minute
sur un trottoir
ils font un écran opaque pour des
enfants qui sortent d'un immeuble et qui
une fois
obligés d'emprunter la voie de tram ou
bus bat ainsi un obstacle arrive c'est
souvent trop tard c'est un véritable
danger visuel donc je pense aussi qu'il
faut que les parents pensent à leurs
enfants que les grands parents pensaient
leurs petits enfants parce que vraiment
aujourd'hui les enfants on les
accompagne à l'école en voiture et on
les dépose en se garant sur les
trottoirs parce que les parents me
disent moi je veux pas quand mon enfant
à 400 mètres à faire au centre-ville qui
sont obligés de descendre cinq ou six
fois sur la voie de bus ou sur la rue
pour contourner des obstacles
maryse et appelle ressemble à quoi la
ville de demain pour vous en termes de
déplacements dans la ville de demain
c'est une combinaison de tous types de
déplacements notamment enfin les
centre-villes je pense qu'on aura
intérêt à éloigner un petit peu la
voiture du centre-ville parce qu'on sait
que en 2050 sûrs à peu près 80% des
habitants sur les centres villes donc il
faut qu'on apprenne à limiter les usages
de la voiture
on sait que comme visée
monsieur que la voiture est utilisée
pour deux à trois kilomètres de
déplacement et je pense qu'il faut
combiner tout mode de déplacement enfin
on voit bien la ville a besoin sont à
réaliser le tram en 2014
ç'a permis de refaire enfin réorganiser
les espaces de limiter les places de
stationnement au centre-ville aussi pour
les voitures on enlevait 600 places de
stationnement mais ça c'est très
critiqué par les automobilistes qui
disent on peut plus accéder en
centre-ville et non il reste encore des
parkings nous avons huit parkings en
ouvrage six parkings d'arriérés il ya un
peu plus de 8000 places de stationnement
tout près du centre-ville donc du coup
on peut pas entendre cet argument là
quand on fait parce que il faut il faut
imaginer que les chaînes de déplacement
elles ne se font pas qu'en voiture
il faut que l'automobiliste il aille à
pied chercher sa voiture et après il
pose sa voiture et après ils se
déplacent à pied sur les 5 10 15
dernières minutes pour pouvoir
effectivement confrontés tous les usages
des déplacements les élus ils ont un
rôle suiveurs au proactif sur ces
questions là il faut suivre les
tendances où il faut inciter les gens en
créant les infrastructures adéquates et
ben il faut les yeux en fait les élus
ils ont je pense tous entendu qu'il ya
une urgence quand l'âme urgence
climatique qui va nous obliger à
repenser nos modes de déplacement donc
c'est à dire ils sont là pour favoriser
effectivement les transports en commun
il va y avoir au niveau de
l'agglomération des locations de vélos
électriques enfin voila tu entendes vers
d'autres modes de déplacement mais il
faut aussi
voilà un petit peu inculquer d'autres
pratiques défend en forçant un petit peu
mais ça se fait pas sans concertation
parce qu'après effectivement si on y va
sans concertation on va droit au clash
une réaction de pierre qui vous dit
pourquoi ne pas fermer les quartiers des
centre-villes aux voitures en créant des
parkings en périphérie et yang garder la
parole à tourner après leur nom à des
parkings relais lors de la création du
train mon ami des parkings relais à
disposition en fait alors je pense les
archis plus ou moins bien qui marche
quand même qu'ils sont peut-être encore
trop mal connu parce que effectivement
c'est facile de poser sa voiture prendre
le tram descendent au centre-ville est
remonté pour reprendre sa voiture ça
évite des embouteillages du stress de la
pollution des conflits
les autres usagers mais il commence à
marcher parkings relais et je pense
qu'ils vont se développer
hugo l'allemand n'est en train de
changer les mentalités il ya un
changement minime qui s'avance petit à
petit effectivement quand on regarde les
part modale de déplacement en france
depuis ces dernières années on voit que
la part de la voiture diminue un petit
peu la part des piétons des cyclistes et
transports en commun augmente un petit
peu à besançon vous disiez c'est 3 4%
les cyclistes oui oui moyenne de 3% sur
le centre-ville c'est 7% mais c'est
ridicule
oui enfin ça peut paraître ridicule
parce qu on part de très très loin un
vrai sens de l'urgence écologique
effectivement c'est tellement ridicule
si on veut espérer pouvoir continuer à
vivre plus ou moins de la même manière
que ces dix dernières années
dans trente ans c'est pas 10 15% qui
vont changer quelque chose
et comment faire changer les habitudes
c'est une question d'infrastructures
dont on entend beaucoup par exemple moi
je prends pas mon vélo parce que je suis
en danger un vélo est-ce que ça c'est ça
passe par les infrastructures par
exemple par des pistes cyclables
sécurisées ça c'est très intéressant
effectivement c'est l'argument
majoritaire pour le fait de continuer à
garder la voiture c'est la voiture qui
s'auto-entretient en fait parce que
comme comme il ya beaucoup de voitures
c'est en est mise en danger un vélo ou à
pied ou à pied et du coup et ben on
continue à maintenir ce fut de voitures
donc ce changement là il va passer ben
en grande partie par les aménagements
les infrastructures qui incite de
laisser sa voiture a laissé sa voiture
par un changement en fait assez assez
globale de d'un mode de vie qui est
complètement autocentré encore de nos
jours
hugo patrick joubert les autobus le vif
comment ce changement c'est vécu comme
une agression parce qu'effectivement
alors on l'a dit depuis le début 80 % à
peu près de l'espace dédié aux
déplacements en ville est consacré aux
déplacements de la voiture mais cet
espace il se réduit et c'est vécu comme
une agression par les automobilistes ça
non pas du tout notre association est là
pour former des automobilistes donc leur
proposer d'autres modes de circulation
le vélo et les transports en commun on
n'est pas tout voiture c'est ça un peu
le dilemme comment représentent la
majorité c'est sûr qu'on étouffe dans
l'attaqué mais attendez on peut pas
faire vous avez l'impression que
l'automobiliste est systématiquement
stigmatiser regardez aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'on parle mais c'est vrai ce
que disait
adjointe à la mairie c'est qu'un peu
dense on a la chance d'avoir les
parkings c'est même pas en périphérie
c'est dans le centre-ville et que les
autorise cela ne sont pas capables de
faire 800 mètres de largeur sur le sur
la boucle
bon ça je suis tout à fait d'accord ces
voitures là elle reste dans les parkings
de proximité devrait pas accéder au
centre ville
et pourtant et pourtant et pourtant
aujourd'hui on voit que bon c'est dû à
quoi
on ne sait pas il faut bien interrogés
et contre interrogés quand même les
automobilistes qui sont garées dans la
rue vous avez pas fait ça ce matin là la
russie vous parlez de la rue juste à
côté la rue la rue battant quand on
monte qui est une rue piétonne alors il
ya grégory qui qui se promène tout
autour de christian terras je pense
qu'il va vous la montrer cet effectif ce
que disent les conducteurs de ces
véhicules là pourquoi ils sont là
aujourd'hui quoi cette rue piétonne et
transformer le dimanche notamment en
parking bassam et d'animation puis ça
évite de rouler trop vite ils tirèrent
excusez moi mais là je peux pas entendre
ça savez vous qu'il ya crois qu'ils
cherchent à vous faire rêver mais il va
y arriver il va y arriver
vous savez il ya quand même une partie
importante de la population qui est
porteuse d'un handicap on peut être âgé
50 % des automobilistes des piétons tués
par des automobilistes ou des véhicules
à moteur en france ont plus de 65 ans on
espère tous vivre dans à proximité chez
soi
pouvoir accéder à sa boulangerie à son
médecin à sa pharmacie quand on sera
vieux et honnêtement à 80 ans être
obligé zigzaguer maintenant les les
malvoyants par exemple ont besoin de de
la ligne verticale qui suivent et de la
ligne horizontale du trottoir pour se
guider si on leur demande de slalomer en
permanence ils finissent par plus sortir
mais les piétons s'accommoder de cela il
ya encore quelques années les piétons
peut-être qu'ils sont accommodait mais
les mentalités changent et vous avez
quand même cette incivilité d'ailleurs
on en parlait tout à l'heure
l'automobiliste son niveau de
citoyenneté il commence à partir du
moment où il est à peu près sûr de
prendre un pv
malheureusement je parle de ceux qui
respectent pas les règles bien sûr il
faut il faut partager l'espace et 80% de
l'espace est dédié à l'automobile 10%
aux voies cyclables aux voies de tram et
bus et 10% pour les trottoirs alors s'il
vous plaît on tout tout transport
commence et se termine par la marche
donc pour les automobilistes aussi c'est
important quand ils sont sur les
trottoirs de pouvoir circuler en
sécurité
laissez-nous ces 10% de trottoirs et
respecter les maris zehaf pourquoi là
alors c'est vrai que c'est un exemple
criant qui est sous nos yeux pourquoi
une rue piétonne est transformé en
parking
que fait la police alors la police
désolé ne travaille pas le dimanche
matin d'humour à la police municipale
après la police nationale l 112 sur
notre mission effectivement cette rue
est une rue piétonne alors 7 comme je
vous disais très difficile à travailler
pour faire changer les mentalités il
faut effectivement tout une concertation
avec les commerçants étalent dizaine
issus et que les contrevenants soient
soit soumis à une amende et puis on
peut-être pas recommencer du coup là
c'est de la politique non bah là c'est
effectivement de la politique mais moi
je souligne quand même tout le travail
qui est fait par les associations dont
notamment l'association trottoirs libre
de dif ketterer et puis de l'association
la bb avec lesquels on travaille
régulièrement pour faire avancer petit à
petit les choses près ce que je ne
désespère pas bon il reste peu de temps
avant la fin du mandat
mais vous rendez compte que c'est vous
les élus qui donc avait le pouvoir de
changer les choses et vous nous dites je
ne désespère pas se dire que vous n'avez
pas l'âme un bac c'est toujours très
compliqué de faire évoluer les
mentalités 1 alors que je pense qu'on
est quand même une majorité être
convaincu qu effectivement il faut que
les choses changent
après on n'a pas toutes les clefs et
filières qu'il ya des pressions
notamment des riverains des
connaissances et centre un peu d'une
partie des commerçants qui ne se sont
encore pas rendu compte que une voiture
n'est pas forcément un client qu'en fait
les commerçants pense qu'effectivement
une voiture ça va leur amener un client
mais on s'aperçoit qu'effectivement
qu'avec toutes les statistiques qui ont
été faites les automobilistes consomme
très peu en vue
si vous permettez je vais je vais vous
interpeller bien que vous ne soyez pas
l'élu en charge de cette question
complètement mais le maire a le pouvoir
de réglementer les questions de
stationnement et de sécurité en ville et
la borne de la diot et de l'awb du bas
de la rue piétons de la rue battant par
exemple mais comme d'autres devaient
devraient être levés plus souvent on
veut on veut faire du et en même temps
vous savez on a un problème avec ça
parce que ça ne marche pas en fait vous
avez une volonté d'avoir une ville moins
polluer d'avoir une meilleure santé pour
les habitants de favoriser les modes
doux et l'intermodalité et en même temps
on veut laisser la même place à la
voiture à l'euro mais des dispositifs en
place mais on les fait on l'est on l'est
on s'en sert pas suffisamment et on l'a
on fait pas respecter les espaces donc
il ya quelque chose de contradictoire
monsieur le maire fait quelque chose
mais c'est peut-être parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'électeurs qui utilisent leur
voiture probablement c'est ce qu'il a
convenu
récemment devant 120 cyclistes et
patrick joubert qu'on était la majorité
donc c'est sûr c'est cette majorité là
qu'il faut faire évoluer et attendez
nous existons depuis avril 1902 puis rue
1900 ont été les premiers à délivrer les
permis de conduire pendant des décennies
c'est l'autonomie klopp qui délivre les
permis de conduire et on a continué la
formation ont été les premiers à avoir
des centres de contrôle technique avant
que la loi soit sorti qu'on a vendu
parce que ça faisait un peu trop au
marketing on investissait dans les
pistes de contrôle des pistes de
formation et on est en permanence
on est là pour former les automobilistes
on n'est pas là pour les opposer aux
piétons aux vélos
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre mais
aujourd'hui on est quand même un million
cinq cent mille membres au niveau de
l'autonomie club ça représente sur toute
la france sa présence comme quelque
chose on est le premier et le seul club
un qui est allé fille à haut niveau
français et on est là en permanence à
des radios nationales dont les seniors
et les piétons
hugo l'allemand vous comprenez ces
freins vous je les comprends je pense
qu'ils sont effectivement grande partie
comportementaux ça fait 50 ans au moins
voire plus que tous les aménagements
territoriaux et urbanistique sont
pensées autour de la voiture et
je comprends que c'est difficile d'en
changer mais là clairement c'est plus
possible tout le monde se rend compte
qu'il ya vraiment de moins en moins de
personnes qui continuent d'affirmer que
plus d'autoroutes à quatre voies en
ville c'est bien
et donc il faut enfin faut réussir à
changer alors il ya plein de choses il
s'est aussi fait partie d'un tout la
conscience écologique évolué il n'y a
pas que la voiture il ya aussi les modes
de consommation tout en fait maryse
heures je rejoins hugo là-dessus
effectivement il ya un gros travail à
faire et un gros travail d'éducation et
moi je crois beaucoup à l'éducation
qu'on peut faire dans les écoles près
des enfants parce que je pense que c'est
plus facile de former un enfant
cyclistes que de former un automobiliste
cycliste en fait elle donc du coup je
crois beaucoup effectivement à toutes
les campagnes d'éducation qu'on peut
mener toutes les campagnes de prévention
qu'on peut mener et la sensibilisation
comme nine
bon eh bien écoutez on va on va rester
là-dessus ce sera le mot de la fin merci
à tous les quatre d'avoir participé à
cette émission où il est déjà midi on
aurait pu passer une heure de débat on
gardera sa commune et soyez bienveillant
tolérants les uns à l'égard des autres
et tout se passera bien sur la route
comme ailleurs dans un instant votre
flash d'information en région
puis la suite de dimension politique
francis letellier reçoit ce midi le
ministre de la culture franck riester
profitez bien de votre dimanche
à la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
débat
[Musique]